Crétin de cerveau, hein ?
Ouais, alors pour ceux qui auraient
raté le premier épisode,
"Crétin de cerveau", c'est une petite série de vidéo
que je vais consacrer à ce qu'on appelle
les "Biais cognitifs".
Toutes ces situations où on commet
des erreurs de jugement
ou on prend des décisions stupides, irrationnelles.
Dans le premier épisode,
je vous avais parlé de l'effet de halo,
le fait qu'on attribue plein de qualités
de personnalité à des gens juste
sur la base de leur apparence physique.
Le deuxième effet dont on va parler aujourd'hui
s'appelle l'effet d'ancrage.
Pour comprendre que c'est que l'effet d'ancrage
on va faire un petit quiz ensemble.
Alors première question :
A votre avis, est-ce qu'une baleine bleue adulte
mesure plus de 49 mètres ?
Alors je vous laisse répondre, oui ou non.
Puis, deuxième question :
A votre avis une baleine bleue, ça mesure combien ?
Si on fait ce petit quiz à un grand nombre de personnes,
la moyenne des réponses qu'on obtient
à la deuxième question c'est 60 mètres.
Par contre si on pose directement
la deuxième question, sans la première,
c'est-à-dire qu'on demande simplement
à des gens d'estimer la taille d'une baleine,
ils vont répondre en moyenne 30 mètres,
soit deux fois moins.
C'est quand même bizarre hein,
c'est quand même la même question,
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a une telle différence
entre les deux situations.
Dans la première situation on a commencé
par poser la question de manière fermée,
en proposant un chiffre et en demandant
une réponse par oui ou non.
Ce chiffre crée ce qu'on appelle un ancrage,
c'est-à-dire qu'il force les gens à réfléchir
dans une certaine gamme de valeur
et du coup à la deuxième question qui,
cette fois, est une question ouverte,
ils vont donner des réponses différentes
de ce qu'ils auraient donné
si on leur avait posé directement
cette deuxième question.
Et du coup, dans ce cas précis ils vont se planter
complètement parce qu'en fait, 30 mètres,
c'était à peu près la bonne réponse,
mais 60 mètres, bah c'est 2 fois trop.
Alors quelque part, on pourrait penser que
ce phénomène est un petit peu normal.
A partir du moment où on nous propose
un chiffre dans la première question
et qu'on part du principe que celui qui nous pose
les questions le fait de manière un peu intelligente,
il est légitime de prendre ce chiffre
comme un indice et donc c'est normal
que ça influence notre réponse à la deuxième question.
Sauf qu'il a deux expériences
qui viennent contredire cette explication.
La première, c'est le fait que l'effet d'ancrage
fonctionne aussi si le chiffre
de la première question est tiré au hasard.
Cette expérience, elle a été faite par
Daniel Kahneman et Amos Tversky
qui sont deux psychologues israélo-américains
qui sont un peu les références mondiales
en matière de biais cognitif.
Retenez bien leur noms parce qu'on va
en parler souvent dans "Crétin de cerveau".
Kahneman a d'ailleurs reçu le prix Nobel d'économie
pour l'ensemble de leurs travaux.
Tversky ne l'a pas eu parce qu'il a eu la mauvaise idée
de mourir quelques années avant.
Alors venons-en à l'expérience.
L'idée c'était de demander à des gens d'estimer
combien il y avait de pays africains
dans le monde en pourcentage du total,
en utilisant comme tout à l'heure
d'abord une question fermée
puis ensuite une question ouverte.
Et on l'a fait de la manière suivante.
On fait tourner devant chaque personne,
une roue numérotée de 0 à 100
et quand la roue s'arrête sur un chiffre, on utilise
ce chiffre comme ancre dans la première question.
Par exemple si la roue tombe sur le chiffre 10,
devant les gens, on leur demande :
Y a t-il plus ou moins de 10%
de pays africains dans le monde ?
Ça, c'est la question fermée.
Et ensuite on leur pose la question ouverte :
A votre avis, combien il y a de pays africains.
En fait, pour bien mettre en évidence l'effet d'ancre,
cette expérience elle a été faite
avec une roue qui était truquée
et qui tombait toujours, soit sur 10, soit sur 65.
Alors on va voir les résultats.
Le premier groupe à qui on demandait d'abord,
à votre avis, y a t-il plus ou moins
de 10% de pays africains,
au final, il a estimé en moyenne qu'il y avait
25% de pays africains dans le monde
et le deuxième groupe qui lui,
était ancré avec le chiffre 65%,
il a estimé qu'il y en avait 45%.
Donc même avec un chiffre d'ancrage
qui a été tiré au hasard devant leurs yeux,
qui n'a pas été choisi par celui qui pose la question
et bien les gens ont été influencés de manière
vraiment significative dans leur réponse.
Et il y a encore plus fort,
non seulement on est capable de se faire ancrer
par des chiffres qui ont été
tirés au hasard devant nos yeux,
mais on peut aussi se faire ancrer par des chiffres
qu'on sait être totalement absurdes.
Par exemple, l'expérience avec la taille de la baleine,
elle a été faite avec les ancrages suivants.
A un premier groupe on a demandé, pensez-vous
qu'une baleine fait plus ou moins que 20 centimètres
et puis pour un autre groupe on a demandé, pensez-vous
qu'une baleine fait plus ou moins de 900 mètres.
Ensuite, comme d'habitude pour les deux,
la question ouverte,
à votre avis c'est quoi la taille d'une baleine ?
Et bien, à cette question, les gens du premier groupe
ont estimé la taille moyenne d'une baleine
à 20 mètres, donc trop bas
et ceux du deuxième groupe à 142 mètres.
Donc même si je vous pose une question
en utilisant une ancre complètement absurde
dont vous savez pertinemment
qu'elle est complètement fausse,
ça va quand même vous influencer.
C'est dingue non ? Crétin de cerveau.
Il y a une autre observation qui est
à la fois amusante et inquiétante,
c'est que plus on utilise
un chiffre précis comme ancre,
plus l'effet d'ancrage va être puissant.
On a demandé à un groupe de gens
d'estimer la valeur d'une maison,
une belle maison, sur une plage californienne,
sur laquelle le prix était déjà affiché.
Pour un premier groupe de gens on leur montrait
la maison avec un prix affiché de 800 000 $
et ils l'ont estimé en moyenne,
bah en dessous à 751 000 $.
Puis on a refait l'expérience avec d'autres gens,
mais cette fois avec un prix affiché de la maison
de 799 800 $, c'est à dire un prix bien précis.
Et cette fois l'estimation moyenne a été 784 000 $.
Un prix plus proche du prix
initialement affiché sur la maison,
c'est-à-dire que l'effet d'ancrage a été plus fort.
Ce qui se passe dans nos crétins de cerveaux
c'est que, plus le chiffre initial est précis,
plus on est forcé à raisonner proche de ce chiffre
pour faire nos propres estimations.
Donc, morale de l'histoire, quelques petits conseils.
Si vous êtes dans une négociation,
premièrement soyez le premier à proposer un chiffre,
histoire d'ancrer l'autre personne.
Deuxièmement, proposez un chiffre bien précis
et puis troisièmement n'hésitez pas à proposer
un chiffre complètement irréaliste.
D'ailleurs à la fin de cette vidéo,
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipee
en me laissant, par exemple, un tip de 487,92 €.
Voilà c'était pour l'effet d'ancrage. J'espère que
le fait d'avoir connaissance de ce biais cognitif
vous permettra dans une certaine mesure
d'y échapper un petit peu
et puis surtout n'oubliez pas que tout ça
a été étudié scientifiquement,
on n'est pas dans la psychologie de comptoir, là.
Je vous ai mis d'ailleurs les références
des publications scientifiques.
Pour moi, ces travaux en psychologie et en sociologie
sont vraiment essentiels
et il mériteraient d'être mieux connus
et dans les prochains épisodes de la série,
on verra encore plein d'autres biais cognitifs
qui font que notre cerveau est vraiment un crétin.
Si vous voulez aller plus loin sur toutes ces questions,
deux chaînes que je vous recommande
qui traitent de thèmes un petit peu similaires.
La première c'est, "la tronche en biais"
qui parle notamment de biais
et la deuxième c'est "Hygène mentale"
qui vous aidera à développer votre esprit critique
et souvent, on a besoin.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo. N'hésitez pas
à la partager notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
pour faire connaître les biais cognitifs
et puis pour m'aider à faire connaitre la chaîne.
Vous pouvez vous abonner bien sûr pour ne rien rater.
Vous pouvez suivre l'actu de la chaîne
sur Facebook, Tweeter
et ceux qui le souhaitent
peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee.
Merci beaucoup à tous les tipeurs
même s'ils ne donnent pas 487.92€.
Puis vous pouvez aussi aller jeter un œil
à mon bouquin que j'ai sorti chez Flammarion.
Voilà merci et à bientôt!